um so there's a new comedian named Matt
R I've seen little clips of him on Tik
Tok here and there he is a comedian
faced criticism for a domestic violence
joke in his new Netflix special natural
selection in response to the backlash he
sarcastically directed critics to a link
for a special needs helmet as an apology
this move further aggravated those upset
by his remarks R defended his comedy
stating his material was aimed at a more
male audience and that his intention was
solely to make people laugh however this
isn't the first instance of controversy
surrounding R's content exactly do you
see this this is what women do women
always ruin everything now they're
trying to ruin comedy guys men you need
to push back on this and tell women to
get the F over it